un discours qui culpabilise les Français
c'est comme ça que vous l'avez vécu bah
oui s'il y a des s'il y a du chômage
c'est à cause des chômeurs s'il y a de
la pauvreté c'est à cause des
bénéficiaires du RSA et s'il y a des si
on n arrive pas à trouver des médecins
c'est à cause des Français qui prennent
trop de rendez-vous et qui viennent pas
bref bah c'est pas un peu caricatural ah
bah c'est ce que j'ai entendu
excusez-moi ENF si ça va mal c'est à
cause de nous et c'est pas de sa faute
c'est comme la smicardisation de la
France il y a le nombre de smicard est
passé en France de 12 % 2017 quand
Emmanuel Macron est arrivé au pouvoir à
plus de 17 % aujourd'hui c'est quand
même pas de notre faute hein c'est quand
même un petit peu le résultat de leur
politique
donc les Français ont bien du mal à
joindre les debout à élever leurs
enfants à payer le facture mais c'est
toujours notre faute et ça ça commence à
bien faire alors hier vous avez dit
c'est pas Gabriel hatal c'est Gabriel
sachur on est quand même loin de la PO
tax qui a été l'un des qui a valu la le
départ de la première ministre
britannique vous forcez pas un petit peu
le Tr sur Gabriel Sacher mais euh ce qui
m'a marqué dans le discours qu'il a
prononcé hier c'est qu'il est allé même
plus loin dans le discours libéral que
celui auquel je m'attendais par exemple
ils ont décidé ça je l'avais pas vu
arriver ils ont décidé de déshabiller la
loi SRU la loi qui impose aux communes
de construire 25 % de logements sociaux
pour pouvoir répondre à la crise du
logement qui est là dans notre pays et
si ces communes n'atteignent pas ces 25
% elles payent une amende et il y a
aujourd'hui des communes plutôt tenu par
la droite et des communes très
bourgeoises qui qui sont fiers même de
payer cette amende c'est c'est c'est un
coup de canif dans le contrat
républicain il a dit qu'il fallait
intégrer dans ce calcul les logements
intermédiaires qui bénéficient au classe
moyenne ouis enfin plus qu'au classe
moyenne ce sont des logements qui ne
sont pas subventionnés justement pour
pouvoir accueillir des familles des des
des classes modaises des classes
populaires des travailleurs des aides
soignantes parce que c'est ça
aujourd'hui hein et bien voilà ils
n'auront plus l'obligation de construire
ces 25 % de logements sociaux pour ces
famillesl et mais ça c'est vous vous
rendez compte la crise du logement qu'il
a dans notre pays c'est c'est je ne sais
pas où ils vivent l'année dernière en
2022 en 2023 la France a construit entre
80000 à 90000 logements sociaux quand
l'objectif était d'en faire 150000 on
est en dessous de tout il y a il y a
plus de 2 millions de Français qui sont
en attente d'un logement social et qui
et et on en a pas parce qu'ils n'en
construisent pas et c'est pas de la
faute des bailleurs c'est de la faute de
l'État qui a augmenté la TVA qui l'a
fait passer de 55 à 10 qui leur
ponctionne au bailleur plus d'un
milliards tous les ans et donc forcément
les bailleurs sont étranglés moi je le
vis dans dans ma commune de
saint-armment Les eau dans les communes
des villages ma circonscription les
bailleurs ont bien du mal à programmer
des opérations de logement donc là avec
les annonces de Monsieur Atal et c'est
pour ça que je vous dis que c'est un
discours qui est très libéral c'est
qu'il est allé plus loin sur des
secteurs comme le logement qui était
déjà en crise qui est un des secteur qui
doit faire le plus d'efforts notamment
pour le défi climatique c'est-à-dire la
rénovation thermique des logements et
cetera mais allez hop c'est c'est
l'économie de marché qui va prendre le
pouvoir et je trouve que ça c'est sur ce
sujet là du logement c'est extrêmement
grave lui a axé son discours sur les
classes moyennes en disant c'est elles
qui ont besoin aujourd'hui qu'on
s'intéresse à elles et qu'on les qu'on
les aide est-ce que la gauche dans les
années précédente n'a pas un peu oublié
ses classes moyennes ce qui a nourri par
exemple une partie du mouvement des
gilets jaunes bah vous savez moi je suis
secrétaire national du Parti communiste
français ouais et donc je rends compte
de la politique et des propositions que
mon parti a défendu ces dernières années
et j'ai été élu en 2018 à peu près en
même temps que Emmanuel Macron lui est
devenu président de la République donc
j'ai vu ce qui s'est passé ce qui se
passe dans mon pays depuis cette période
et ce que nous nous avons défendu ce que
nous voulons pour le monde du travail
pour les retraités pour la jeunesse de
notre pays nous nous battons nous pour
que l'ensemble des salaires soit indexé
sur l'inflation et que pour tous les
Français qui travaillent puissent vivre
de leur travail nous faisons de ce
combat contre la vie chère et pour la
dignité du monde du travail le cœur de
notre projet de société reconstruire une
France du travail où chacun puisse vivre
de son métier de son travail en tenant
compte de l'ancienneté des compétences
on a un gouvernement qui depuis cette
date depuis 2017 depuis qu'Emmanuel
Macron est arrivé qui a complètement
déshabillé la France du travail il a
précarisé le travail il a smicardisé le
pays on est à plus de 3 millions de
personnes vivant au SMIC et et et et
ceux qui sont au-dessus du SMIC ne
voient pas leur salaire augmenter nous
avons aujourd'hui des Français qui
doivent travailler 2 ans de plus avec la
réforme de retraite passé à 64 ans nous
nous avons combattu ces mesures
d'injustice sociale et nous avons voulu
nous avons fait des propositions pour
reconstruire une France du travail et
c'est proposition on été balayé d'un ver
de main et le bilan il est là
aujourd'hui sans parler de notre
agriculture mais je pense qu'on va on va
y R on vair on a un pays qui est
complètement passé à la moulinette des
politiques
libérales